what's up Katie humans I'm so excited
because we just dropped our human good
collection called surface-level I'm
wearing other shirts it's literally the
most comfortable thing in the world you
have to go to human gait la comm to
check out all the rest of the shirts and
everything else that we have on there
but we're selling out like lightning
fast so you have to go right now
literally right now I do use the n-word
but I only say it when I'm around fellow
black people so my friends or my family
who are black but at the same time I'm
like I don't look black so when it comes
out of my mouth they're like whoa yes
sir I am mixed with African and Asian I
am more Asian than black my dad was from
El Salvador and my mom is half Japanese
half Jewish my ethnicity is Filipino and
black I do feel more inclined to my
black side more than my Filipino side my
mother is white and my dad is Iranian
all throughout high school I just
pretended I was white because I looked
very white
I am half chinese half Russian Jewish I
never really connected to either side
just somewhere in the middle
my mom is Jamaican and my dad is
Australian being mixed race as a race so
I don't feel like I want to have to pick
[Music]
as a mixed black person a lot of people
are like oh my god like you're like
light-skinned you look so nice like you
don't look like all the other ghetto
girls and I'm like is that supposed to
mean that's my own exactly on first
dates most of the time people be like oh
no wonder you're so attractive or like
no wonder you're so gorgeous and I'm
just like I don't love that reaction
I've always found like it's like just an
awkward thing to bring up in
conversation cuz there's like all the
memes were like people like oh did you
know like I'm mixed or whatever and it's
like bringing it up and like the natural
flow conversation is always kind of
weird I need to see these memes do not
seem like the the logic memes or he's
like oh I'm biracial and it's like you
haven't seen oh he's just always
bringing up how he's like half black and
that's like what the meme is
me personally I do not say the n-word I
just I just don't I just doesn't flow
outright but like for my agents I
obviously can call my like fellow
girlies chinks and stuff but like
obviously if someone else said that you
get the fist I agree um I do use the
n-word but I only say it when I'm around
fellow black people so my friends or my
family who are black but at the same
time I'm like I don't look black so what
it comes out of my mouth they're like
whoa I try my best to only use the
n-word around like my black friends just
cuz it creates this like weird air when
I'm with like white people it's a
slippery slope that I don't like to go
down probably makes them really uh and
not actually like more than you think
it's not even uncomfortable a lot of
them think it's really cool and then
some people will feel entitled to do
that and then you just don't want to
have that conversation that was me of my
Asian friends yes like a lot of Asian
people though I like to think going to
black culture sometimes yes I did get
into a little bit of an altercation in
high school for calling white people
colonists that was and people were like
that's a racial slur I don't think it is
that and not personally I don't feel
comfortable using any slurs if I haven't
heard those slurs towards me then maybe
I am not in a position to reclaim them
your race three two one go
in America today walking down the street
it matters what you look like people are
gonna judge you based on the race that
they perceive you to be when I walk down
the street people aren't gonna look at
me the same way as they look at someone
who's perceived as black and so I just
want to like really acknowledge the
reality of that I wouldn't disagree with
you at all but at the same time I think
the most important thing is just how you
grew up someone that has a black parent
that doesn't appear black they were
still raised by a black person they
still like everything that their parents
experiences passed down to them whether
it's through story or just through
actions I'm actually gonna move over to
this line which is I guess more of a
middle line just because I can't do that
then I'm here so I'm on somewhat agree
because I'm an actor and when I go into
casting calls it only matters what I
look like and it only matters what race
they think I am which is a lot of times
white but I'll sometimes I'll get called
in for things that are not my ethnicity
and that's because of my career that's
what's important with that
even throughout high school I just
pretended I was white completely and
there was a time when my dad picked me
up from school it was a whole thing and
people were saying like Oh your dad's a
terrorist I had never experienced
anything like that or they'd asked me
about it they'd make bomb jokes and it
it hurt to hear people saying stuff like
that about my dad a similar thing
happened to me like when I was in
elementary school my dad came and
dropped me off at school and he's like a
dark skinned black man and he's from the
hood on top of that so like he has a
certain like aura to him and a lot of
people look at me like that's your dad
and I'm like yeah that's my dad and
they're like he looks so scary and I'm
like why does he look scary to you why
should he look scary to you and like the
only thing that's keeping me away from
this strongly disagree is because when I
was younger I just did not accept the
black part of myself and now I do I just
want to say I'm really sorry like to
both you that you felt like you've been
put in positions to feel like that
that's just like such a terrible thing
to tell someone now you can't be every
part of who you are these past couple
years I've been trying to like reconnect
with that part because I shoved it down
for so long and it's it's been really
heartbreaking the amount of no dues is I
missed and the Ramadan I didn't
celebrate because I felt so
uncomfortable about that I think it's
important to taking the steps though
personally just I've never tried to hide
any part of me that's always been like
the biggest thing for me growing up like
I was always proud to be white and I was
always proud to be black that's just how
I was raised and it's always how I was
and I just wanted to be me so that's
what I did
the reason I'm on this line is because
Western beauty standards suck they
really really got to me I would be
really picky about how I would do my
hair and how I would part my hair and
then when I would post YouTube videos or
Instagram posts I would color correct
everything to be really blue so that I
didn't look yellow and it was just like
I I didn't want to post a photo of me
outside because I thought my eyes look
too asian a lot of internalized things
that made me feel made me hate myself
and my appearance and now I feel much
more accepting of being mixed and being
everything that I am but I am here
because I have felt like I wanted to
hide a part of me because it would have
been easier for me I agree like when I
was younger I used to want to be lighter
I used to get made fun of I would always
get the question are you adopted you're
not Asian and it just made me feel so
bad about myself that I just was so
confused cuz I didn't fit in any single
pocket of anybody at any friend groups I
couldn't hang out the Chinese kids
because they're like you don't look
Chinese I don't hang out the black kids
because I don't sound black and they say
I'm whitewashed so I my whole entire
life I've literally battled with them
like what the hell am I
[Music]
maybe um so I feel like I just have to
say that in writing college essays every
single one of my essays was about being
half Iranian and half white like when I
was applying for scholarships that's
what I would talk about because it was
something that I really felt passionate
about but also that something that I
knew would catch people's interest and I
think I I don't feel guilty about using
that because I think it's a double-edged
sword and there's lots of repercussions
for being mixed race too well I kind of
interpreted it differently like I
haven't really abused my power like that
like sure that isn't like that but like
I didn't I haven't done anything else
besides that unlike my college apps so I
don't know if I can do this but maybe
I'm gonna like straddle these two okay
then I'll like daintily pose over here
but like my grandma's jew was Jewish and
I did go on birthright which is a free
trip for people of Jewish descent and
even though I don't like identify a lot
with a Jewish religion I did get a free
trip to Israel out of being part Jewish
so I guess that's like kind of something
to my advantage but I really loved my
time there yeah yeah but you know I've
like gotten like jobs for being half
Asian for like like I worked at mostly
to predominantly Asian businesses and as
soon as I say I speak fluent Cantonese I
got the job look like a skill I know you
can be proud of
no I love it no trust me but I it does
get me job opportunities better than
other people who are like you know white
or black who get the same positions but
they would hire me because I'm half
asian and like I speak the language and
stuff okay I moved because I was
thinking more about the question when I
first heard the question I was thinking
like do I have any kind of advantage and
then I was thinking about how like being
part white does give me some privilege
and like some advantages but I don't
think I've used that for like
scholarships or any of that and I've try
to really stay conscious when I'm in
like an Asian space
to not take up too much of the space
because of my whiteness you know like
it's like a bits of cyberspace like
you're so yeah I guess I've always been
kind of cautious about that but thinking
more about the question I was like no I
should be on this side I there are way
too many articles about a interracial
couple where it's later find out that
the white part is saying a racial slur
about their child just to boil it down
to like love it can't really can't be
done first of all that second of all
there's a lot of sorry to name names but
like a lot of white men women who want
to get with black men trying to achieve
their light-skinned baby who's like just
the perfect amount of tan with the
perfect amount of curls
yeah like raise your hand if you've
heard someone be like oh my gosh I would
have such gorgeous mixed babies like
definitely heard that and we're all
gorgeous don't get me wrong but that's
super problematic to say 1 & 2 I'm over
here because like there is like no one
solution to racism let me make it really
clear that a white person having a kid
with a black person does not mean that
that person does not have racist
tendencies or is not discriminatory at
all I love my dad to death but he
sometimes he just says things where it's
like you shouldn't be saying that that's
like even in like a future if if like
America becomes super mixed and like
everybody's mixed if not racism it will
solve like colorism and you know
different nuances within racism it's not
gonna go away just because people are
more mixed like you can say like mixed
people or the future or whatever but
it's not gonna solve racism
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey guys I hope you enjoyed that episode
don't forget to check our new human good
collection surface-level this whole
collection is about how we make
judgments and how frequently we make
them on a surface level so get a human
get la comm to check out the rest of the
items in the collection but hurry up
because we're selling out really fast
you can also follow us on instagram at
human gait LA and we will see you next
time